is the new 14 inch macbook pro really  worth a thousand dollars more than the  m1 macbook air the new 14 inch macbook  pros definitely heavier  [Music]  this is the macbook air's 720p webcam  the 14-inch macbook pro has a 1080p  webcam the new 14-inch has a higher  resolution display i can't see a  noticeable difference to my eyes there's  no difference in terms of color grading  and things like that playing back hdr  photos or video you guys can see the  difference cinebenches throttle test the  macbook air is actually cooler we have a  difference of 40  if you care about silence there's no  reason to go for the macbook air if you  can afford the 14 inch adobe lightroom  over here let's run an export test 63  faster if you don't push him hard the m1  macbook air is much lighter it'll get  better battery life and you're saving so  much cash